et notre invité politique ce matin c'est
frédéric valletoux bonjour bonjour merci
beaucoup d'être avec nous vous êtes
maire de fontainebleau membres d'agir
vous êtes le président de la fédération
hospitalière de france on est ensemble
pendant 20 minutes pour une interview en
partenariat avec la presse quotidienne
régionale bonjour pascal jalabert du
groupe les bras les journaux régionaux
de l'est de la france
évidemment on va commencer en parlant d
emmanuel macron faudrait pas tout
puisqu'il est attendu ce soir à 20
heures il s'exprimera notamment sur la
crise sanitaire qu'est ce que vous
attendez vous ce soir du chef de l'état
quel discours il doit délivrer aux
français selon vous chose qui il doit
délivrer un discours dans la continuité
de ce qui a été toujours çà çà çà
posture c'est à dire d'essayer autant
que possible face à une crise qu on
apprend à connaître aussi en marchant
depuis 18 mois et bien éclairé autant
possible le l'avenir d'aller redonner un
cap un sens à des mesures qui
inévitablement vont devoir être sans
doute un peu un peu comment dire précisé
pour être pour permettre effectivement
le moindre compte y mettre des
contaminations de ce qu'on voit
aujourd'hui de 7 2 7 de cette épidémie
c'est à dire des restrictions à nouveau
falloir donner un tour de vis cependant
en tout cas rappelé que les gestes
barrière rappelé le minimum minimorum
rappeler à quel point l'été et le retour
à une à une à une vie je veux dire à une
hanche à lens ne peut pas être permise
parce que derrière il ya effectivement
ce variant delta qui qui est là qui est
déjà là massivement là que ces
invariants différent des autres et donc
il y doit redonner un peu du sens à tout
cela a réexpliqué la parole
présidentielle ces paroles qu'ils
portent et donc il doit peut-être dire
avec une certaine solennité ce que des
médecins et des spécialistes disent déjà
depuis quelques semaines ou quelques
mois
mais que le président la république bien
sûr quand c'est lui qui l'expriment en
posant le cadre en traçant la ligne en
traçant des perspectives
évidemment la parole porte différemment
et c'est vous le constatez vous ce
relâchement
c'est un risque oui inévitablement par
moments
c'est un risque aussi moi je suis fière
par exemple je suis allé dans des grands
magasins hier je vois qu'il ya pu
tellement de règles et qu'on ne fait
plus attention on ne compte plus les
visiteurs dans les grands magasins au
moment où il rentre voilà donc qui on
voit bien ce relâchement est ce qu est
ce que je devais le gouvernement
emmanuel macron qui n'ont pas des
confiné trop vite est ce que le message
portait depuis des semaines en disant
ben on en a fini avec le virus est
derrière nous c'était un peu ça le
message aussi est-ce que ça ça n'a pas
été trop rapide de la part du
gouvernement
est-ce que ce n'était pas une erreur ce
que je comprends pas je crois qu'il ya
toujours cet équilibre à trouver entre
effectivement les contraintes sanitaires
mais aussi le le contexte économique et
social qui doit être pris en compte
s'est pas relâché trop vite
si jamais effectivement les gestes
minimum sont respectés et si des règles
minimales
elles aussi sont respectés donc lâché
trop vite aussi face à une épidémie qui
surprend là on a un variant qui se
développe beaucoup plus vite que ce
qu'on avait vu jusqu'à présent
donc tous les pays cherchent la bonne
solution martingale regarder
l'angleterre était ont tressé des
lauriers abri johnson et aux anglais il
ya quelques mois aujourd'hui on voit
qu'ils sont à nouveau
dans une certaine difficulté parce que
parce que tout le monde ne s'est pas
fait vacciner parce que le variant delta
est beaucoup plus agressif qu'on
imaginait ya quelques mois voilà donc ce
sont des données qu'on ne peut pas le
dire prédire et heureusement oui alors
la grande question c'est évidemment la
vaccination obligatoire ou pas très
clairement faut-il à rendre obligatoire
pour les personnels soignants avec moi
depuis depuis l'automne dernier c'est à
dire à partir du moment où on a su que
la campagne de vaccination a démarré en
janvier
j'ai plaidé nous avons plaidé à la
fédération hospitalière de france pour
que la vaccination soit obligatoire pour
tous les publics qui prennent en charge
les personnes les plus fragiles donc
évidemment les publics soignant mais pas
qu'eux qui a vu que sa vision vernement
a trop tardé pour vous là sans doute on
sur l'espagne effectivement d'une
certaine voilà on a pensé que tout le
monde allait se précipiter ce faire soit
de se faire des gâteaux
moi je pense qu'on aurait dû le rendre
obligatoire ça aurait été beaucoup plus
simple beaucoup plus lisible les
soignants ont déjà un certain nombre de
vaccins qui sont obligatoires lorsque
vous êtes embauché dans un hôpital
restent b voilà il ya une dizaine de
vaccins qui sont obligatoires d'autres
donc cher ça n'aurait pas été ce
n'aurait pas été choquant de dire ce
vaccin est obligatoire pour les
soignants comme pour d'autres
professions je leur dis qu'ils sont en
contact avec des publics ou des publics
nombreux seniors exemple les enseignants
et je pense qu'aujourd'hui le débat qui
doit y avoir et j'attends du président
de la république ce soit qui
effectivement ils deviennent sur cette
question là qu'il rendre la vaccination
obligatoire pour les publics pour les
professionnels pardon qui sont en
contact avec des publics nombreux des
publics fragiles bien sûr pas uniquement
les soignants d'avant parce que ce
serait montrer du doigt la
responsabilité des feuillants je pense
que depuis 18 mois les soignants montré
qu'ils étaient au rendez vous et qui
faisait face pendant les conditions pas
toujours faciles on en parlera peut-être
mais au delà de d'aidé soignant il ya
d'autres publics qui effectivement sont
susceptibles de transmettre et qu'à
partir de là il faut il jouer pour vous
faut quand même vaccinale à plus de
professions cette vaccination
obligatoire faut quand même là réservé à
certains publics faut pas que ça soit
une vaccination obligatoire pour tous
très franchement anti personnel si
demain
si ce soir pardon le présent la
république annonce qu' il va organiser
une vaccination obligatoire pour tous
les français dans des modalités qui
restent à définir bien sûr ça peut être
du jour au lendemain mais moi ça ne me
choquerait pas parce qu'effectivement on
l'a aussi dire quand on a tous des
vaccins qui sont obligatoires si on veut
définitivement est réellement se sortir
de cette affaire il faut aller vers des
mesures radicales on voit bien que l'on
va être sinon dans un risque c'est cette
course aux variants parce qu'aujourd'hui
on parle des variants delta et qui vous
dit que dans 2 3 m'en parlera pas d'un
autre variante encore plus agressif au
personne ne peut le dire personne ne
peut le savoir
donc je pense que la plus grande
prudence ce serait d'aller vers des
solutions qui soient une couverture
maximale pour terminer sur cette
question de la vaccination obligatoire
est ce qu'il faut des sanctions pour les
soignants réfractaires bon je pense pas
qu'il faut aller des sanctions parce que
les sanctions ça veut dire quoi ça veut
dire qu'on dise à des soignants qui ne
veut pas se faire vacciner
on confond vous sort on vous exclus on
vous renvoie
aujourd'hui on a besoin de tout le monde
à l'hôpital et dans tout le système de
santé
il est mise à mal par cette épidémie
il a des dysfonctionnements que l'on
connaît on a besoin réellement de tout
le monde donc il s'agit pas d'aller
commencé à exclure néanmoins je pense
que l'élan fera que même si on n'est pas
à 100% on va partir au moment où il ya
une injonction a suffisamment forte pour
effectivement aller vers la vaccination
pour les soignants semaines on avait
misé sur l'élan y aura pas de réelle
obligation après peut-être il faut peut
être écarté des services les plus
sensibles les personnels qui ne veulent
pas voilà falloir trouver des fonctions
qui les écartent des des patients et
donc finalement une dégradation de ce
que peuvent apporter à l'hôpital
à partir du moment où il ne se
soumettrait pas à la loi je pense qu'il
faudrait éviter d'aller vers
effectivement des exclusions qui
n'aurait pas de sens dans le contexte
actuel est-ce que l'élan il est déjà là
puisque maintenant ce débat sur la
vaccination obligatoire il a quelques
jours voire quelques semaines est ce que
vous d'après les remontées vous avez
vous voyez des soignants qui se font de
plus en plus vaccinée ou il ya pas d y a
pas de dynamique siph mais oui on les
soignants se vaccine de plus en plus
comme d'ailleurs on voit depuis quelques
jours les français de plus en plus
nombreux dans les centres de vaccination
mois samedi à fontainebleau on a fait
2200 vaccination dans la journée ce qui
pour nous et c'est un gros centres de
vaccination a plus de grosse capacité
mais enfin c'est un record qu'on a eue
alors ça suffit pas une journée ne
suffit pas à faire un printemps de la
vaccination
néanmoins
on voit qu'il ya à nouveau plus de
rendez-vous qui sont pris et tant mieux
donc les soignants participe aussi de
cet élan et dans les établissements
publics comme privés et parce que ça il
s'agit de parler de tous les soignants
même les libéraux
effectivement il ya plus de il y avait
derrière mouvement vers plus de
vaccination mais peut-être il faut aller
vers une obligation effectivement et
j'espère ce soir elle sera annoncée
alors faut-il limiter l'accès à
certaines manifestations à certains
lieux aux personnes vaccinées ou alors
rendre le pass annie terre beaucoup plus
obligatoire qui ne l'est aujourd'hui
moi je vous je pense oui de même qu'il
faut fuite déremboursés c'est à dire
rendre payant l'accès aux tests pcr qui
sont les thèses pcs de pcs de confort
vous voulez voyager vous voulez aller un
concert vous voulez peut-être demain
aller au cinéma on verra ce que sont les
conditions qui sont mises en place il ya
aucune raison que la sécurité sociale
donc la solidarité nationale vous
financent eux pcr à partir mouiller à la
vaccination est gratuite et simple
d'accès du jour au lendemain
vous avez des vaccins donc à partir du
moment où la vaccination est simple
d'accès et gratuite ya aucune raison
qu'on continue à payer des tests pcr de
confort c'est différent si bien sûr vous
avez des symptômes ou si vous n'êtes
qu'un contact mais par contre les tests
que j'appelle de confort ou d'agrément
et bien cela il faut effectivement les
faire les rendre payant ce qui poussera
les gens vers vers la vaccination
certainement et sur le passe à l'unité
reste qu'il faut abaisser les jauges les
restaurants les salles watts alouettes à
un ensemble de mesures qui doit être
annoncée ce soir
l'obligation vaccinale pour certains on
verra on l'a dit un instant et le
renforcement des dépasse débat
sanitaires pour l'accès voilà certaines
sa féminité
pourquoi pas au restaurant bien sûr
pourquoi pas au restaurant et je veux
des les grands magasins que j'ai
fréquenté hier pourquoi pas leur donner
aussi le pass sanitaire envoyée
rendre obligatoire le pass and i ter
dont on peut on peut améliorer les
conditions que c'était de prévention et
finalement rendre plus efficaces
certaines mesures
laissons pas encore plus loin et limiter
certains lieux aux seules personnes qui
ont reçu leur dose de vaccin pas
sanitaire au vaccin août est baissière
mais uniquement vaccin uniquement vous
c'est pas ça n'est pas sanitaires aussi
récent parce que sinon à sont là autant
rendre obligatoire ce qui pourra être
fait mais rendre obligatoire la
vaccination ce qui n'est pas ce qui
n'est pas aujourd'hui le cas une
attention vous allez faire un feu
d'artifice le 14 juillet dans votre
commune ont je fais pas de feu
d'artifice jeu normalement je fais un
feu d'artifice le la fin août c'est
comme ça je les annuler par contre on va
effectivement faire ce qu'on appelle un
grand pique nique sur la grande place
mais on veillera à ce que les tables
soit très espacées que les gens portent
le masque en barlow mobile et film
évidemment ils mangent donc on sera
vigilant sur les conditions sanitaires
là aussi il faut essayer de trouver
l'articulation entre le retour un
semblant de vie sociale ou à une vie
sociale tant qu'on peut et puis malgré
tout le respect des contraintes et sur
la question sur le port du masque qui a
certaines communes qui est remettent le
port du masque obligatoire est ce que
vous savez votre cas pour l'instant je
n'envisage pas je le comprends certaines
communes qui sont très touristiques ont
peut-être des rues étroites avec de la
densité de population très forte à la et
qui voit arriver l'été avec c'est que
les français vont plus à nouveau partir
chez eux c'est-à-dire en france et donc
ça peut amener dans certaines villes
très touristique à une bd des densités
de population qui tout d'un coup peut
effectivement rendre utile à nouveau le
le port du masque sur l'espace public
pour l'instant tout de suite à
fontainebleau c'est pas c'est pas on n'a
pas besoin encore on va parler du reste
de ce qu'on peut attendre un de
l'allocution d'emmanuel macron il
parlera évidemment créé sanitaire mais
peut-être pas que est ce que pour vous
il doit parler de réforme ce soir où est
ce que ce n'est pas le bon moment
je pense qu'il doit parler de réforme
parce qu'il doit pas donner le ghana n'a
l'impression d'un président ou d'un
gouvernement à l'arrêt
parce que la vie continue et je vais
prendre un seul exemple qui est
l'exemple que que l'on évoque le système
de santé
il faut un an après le ségur de la santé
montré que pour notre système de santé
pas que pour l'hôpital pour notre
système de santé
il ya encore effectivement d d d d idées
la nécessité de porter un certain nombre
de réformes structurelles
alors peut-être pas qu'ils vont être
plus qui vont évidemment pas être menées
dans les prochains mois mais à une loi
de financement de la sécurité sociale
qui arrive dans quelques dans quelques
mois au début de l'automne
on doit avoir des signaux de mise en
oeuvre du du du ségur de la santé dit un
an
il doit commencer à lever le voile aussi
là dessus donc c'est une question de
mise en oeuvre du secteur de la santé où
c'est que le ségur de la santé en
lui-même il va pas assez loin d'alors le
c ur de la santé pour l'instant il y
avait quatre chantiers douvaine y en a
qui a été aboutis mais il reste trois
autres l'investissement la
débureaucratisation la simplification du
système de santé et jédir contourne le
système de santé vers les territoires
ces trois aspects là n'ont pas été
vraiment traiter jusqu'à présent et donc
je les français attendent que présente
la république le gouvernement conforte
un système de santé et un hôpital au
coeur de ce système de santé dont on a
vu à quel point il était utile et
nécessaire
à partir de là les sauts qui a été
annoncé il ya déjà quelques mois doit
effectivement être mises en oeuvre
c'est à dire et de démesure pour venir
conforter notre système de santé
et là-dessus le compte n'y est pas
complètement injustement sur ce sujet ce
qui préoccupait beaucoup nos lecteurs et
téléspectateurs c'est en gros le désert
médical qui gagne du terrain et pas
seulement sur les spécialistes ça vient
aussi sur les généralistes
ça vous inquiète et comment le résoudre
faut-il imposer ben sortie de d'études
qu'on aille dans tel ou tel territoire
alors déjà un constat les déserts
médicaux ça fait déjà quelques années
qu'on les voit venir et et
malheureusement ça fait on va on va les
vies de meilleures encore beaucoup plus
forte beaucoup plus accrue cette
difficulté d'accès aux soins encore
pendant quelques années on a une petite
dizaine d'années de difficultés devant
nous
où effectivement les générations qui
partent à la retraite vont être beaucoup
plus nombreuses que ceux qui
s'installent donc il faut absolument
arriver à redonner envie aux soignants
d'abord de rentrer dans fil des études
mais ça on en verra les effets sur les
terrains que au terme de leurs études
ces indices 15 ans mais au-delà de ça
déjà à ceux qui sont déjà dans les
métiers du soin de ne pas quitter ses
métiers parce que par excès de
bureaucratie par excès difficulté par
par manque aussi de l'attractivité
quand vous avez une consultation à 25
euros pour le généraliste c'est pas
super attractifs surtout si vous lui
demandez passé plus d'une demi-heure
avec son patient voire trois quarts
d'heure avec son patient
les carrières à l'hôpital il ya eu un
effort de fait un effort totalement
inédit un presque 7 milliards d'euros
qui ont été mis sur la table pour
améliorer les carrières l'hôpital
néanmoins on est sur des niveaux de
salaires qui restent modestes et surtout
des difficultés de progression de
progression dans la carrière qu'ils sont
peu attractifs pour des jeunes et qui
parfois font que vu la charge de travail
et gens jettent l'épongé et partent au
milieu de leur carrière et donc on perd
des forces pour la forme et donc tout
cela ces sondes et d'éléphants auquel il
faut s'atteler tout de suite pour
essayer effectivement d'oreiller ces
difficultés qu'on connaît donc tous les
territoires de trouver un médecin
d'avoir accès à une consultation
ça va être de plus en plus compliqué il
faut absolument mener à bien ses
réformes
rendre le système plus simple mieux le
financer laurent l'écart ya plus
attractive ce sont des chantiers qui
avaient très bien pointé le président de
république dès septembre 2018 donc il
n'a pas attendu la crise pour pointer
ces sujets là maintenant il s'agit pas
simplement de pointer les sujets il faut
maintenant les mettre en oeuvre
et là dessus il ya un tout petit temps
de retard le plan plus qu'un petit temps
parce que ça fait deux ans et demi le
sujet
manière de dire il ya un temps de retard
certain alors évidemment le système de
santé ccc un paquebot
et pour arriver à loix bouger il faut il
faut cesser long entre le moment où on
décide des choses et ça se met en rang 9
mais néanmoins c'est vrai que je donne
un seul exemple sur l'investissement
hospitalier en novembre 2019 edouard
philippe annonce un plan de relance de
l'investissement de rendu d'autant plus
nécessaire qu'entretemps la crise arrive
et on s'aperçoit et dans quel état de
difficultés le système hospitalier où
l'ensemble du système de santé
il ya urgence à relancer
l'investissement bon ben on est
aujourd'hui en juillet 2021
on commence seulement seulement
seulement un an après le segura main
doit presque un an et demi après les
premières annonces a à voir arriver les
crédits pour permettre de relancer
l'investissement speziali qui est
dramatiquement bas donc c'est vrai qu'il
ya une inertie qui est très forte
une inertie qui est très forte et puis
il ya le risque aussi une fois que la
crise va influer de revoir revenir tout
les réflexes bureaucratique que l'on n'a
plus du tout envie de revoir sur le
terrain parce que l'un des grands acquis
de 2,7 de cette crise c'est que sur le
terrain les médecins les directeurs les
cadres les infirmières tout ça ils ont
dans l'urgence trouver des solutions
pour faire face aux situations d'urgence
et finalement trouver des solutions
qui loin la bureaucratie d'arrêt
bureaucratique disons pas envie qu'on
leur impose ce bureaucratisme qui
longtemps détesté on parle du
bureaucratisme ce qu'on va parler de la
loi de décentralisation mais d'abord un
dernier mot sur l'hôpital parce qu'il ya
200 parlementaires qui veulent un
référendum d'initiative partagée sur
cette question de l'hôpital pour un
accès universel un service public de
santé de qualité vous soutenez cette
démarche
quand j'ai vu cette démarche elle est
intéressante parce que elle elle elle
contribue à mettre le sujet de l'hôpital
de la place de l'hôpital dans système de
santé et finalement du système de santé
sur la table et dans le débat public
néanmoins je la trouve un peu trop
spital au centre et parce qu'une des
difficultés l'hôpital sais pas ce qui se
passe dans les quatre murs de l'hôpital
une des difficultés l'hôpital c'est
effectivement qu'elle est aussi géré
pèsent sur l'hôpital tous les
dysfonctionnements du système de santé
on parlait la crise de la médecine
libérale de l'accès au sud de la crise
du manque de médecins généralistes à ce
fonds voilà donc ça si vous voulez c'est
pas le fait de l'hôpital et pourquoi y
ait autant de monde aux urgences si les
gens trouvaient dans les cabinets de
ville des forces syndicales pour les les
recevoir il n'y aurait pas tout cette
pression sur l'hôpital dont on voit bien
que l'hôpital il a des problèmes en
lui-même je dis pas que il n'ya pas un
sujet à l'hôpital il a des problèmes et
plusieurs problèmes mais néanmoins il
n'est pas non plus il n'est pas l'unique
objet du système de santé et donc s'il
faut regarder plus largement cette cette
initiative et je trouve très hospital au
centre et elle est bon c'est une vue
partielle du sujet il ya des vraies
questions qui sont posées effectivement
sur l'accès universel ça c'est un vrai
sujet donc je je je je je regarde cette
initiative pour l'instant je la soutiens
pas particulièrement je l'aurait pas
rédigée comme ça j'aurai vu quelque
chose de plus amples et qui emmène aussi
la médecine libérale parce
qu'aujourd'hui une crise la médecine
libérale qui nous est retraité donc
c'est cette loi alors 3ds cadet des
concentrations décentralisation on y
voit pas très clair faut-il à simplifier
et comment lui donner un peu envie de
transformer le pays ben j'ai compris que
le passé un peuple un peuple à côté du
sujet ce jeu en tant que maire je
je vois pas le jeu voit le souffle d'une
réforme dans cette dans ce projet de loi
les sénateurs que ça manque de souffle
jeudi des réactions très mitigées des
associations effectivement des
associations d'élus bon on va dire c'est
une loi de fin de quinquennat qui ne
veut fâcher personne et qui donc ne
tranche pas grand chose on ne clarifie
pas les compétences personne ne voulant
fâcher personne on ne satisfait personne
puisque de toute façon il est difficile
se noie décentralisation où vous avez
tant d'acteurs condé condé jédir des
visées et des objectifs différents de
pouvoir faire plaisir à tout le monde
donc effectivement cette loi on clarifie
pas clairement les compétences on ne
résout pas la question du mille feuilles
qui parfois sur le terrain est
totalement abracadabrantesque on ne
règle pas la question de l'état sur les
territoires en l'état sur les
territoires c'est un vrai sujet
d'autorité de clarification duty fait
quoi et c'est donc c'est vrai que tout
ça n'est pas traité la question
financière n'est pas abordée l'autonomie
financière ou fiscale des collectivités
qui est dans la constitution mais que
sur le terrain on ne voit plus vivre
soit en amont en amande le sujet dans la
constitution et et soit on redonne des
moyens aux collectivités d'exercer cette
autonomie nos ya quand même des sujets
de fond sur la décentralisation qui ne
sont pas traités donc il y en a eu
tellement des textes comme ça au
finalement aurait écrit des virgules
on précise des phrases dans les yeux que
dans les textes existants mais on qu'on
ne transforme pas comme on a pu faire en
82 et les lois defferre en 2004 avec les
lois à ça c'était des moments où les
lignes ont bougé ou les curseurs ont
bougé bon ben là c'est une mois de mai
par les défendeurs fin de quinquennat
faut-il faire celle des retraites avant
la fin du quinquennat
alors c'est des retraites moi je pense
que un sujet comme celui loi ce comme
celui-là doit doit doit attendre
président prendra les responsabilités
qui sont les siennes et fera ce qu'il
veut dire pensent bon pour le pays
moi je pense néanmoins que il faudrait
attendre parce que justement aujourd'hui
d'abord la crise est toujours là et on
va en parler dit il en parlera ce soir
et est ensuite effectivement des
réformes de fond comme celle là ne
peuvent pas saborder en fin de
quinquennat parce qu'en fin de
quinquennat tout le monde a la tête dans
qu'il sera candidat qui sera pas
candidat je suis pour machin ou contre
le truc et donc les vrais sujets sont
mal abordé
je pense que c'est cccc des réformes
systémiques en tout cas pour qu'elle
soit pour qu'elle soit utile il faut
qu'elle soit systémique qu'à partir de
là c'est un contrat entre un
effectivement un ou enfin un nouveau
président une nouvelle majorité qui le
met dans son don dans son contrat avec
le pays et qui ensuite par contre
n'hésite pas à mettre en oeuvre et à
faire ce qu'il a dit qu'il ferait
l'actualité ce week-end marqué par cette
agression mortelle qui a eu lieu dans un
centre commercial de claye-souilly 7 ans
et un jeune homme de 18 ans qui a été
tuée à coups de couteau il s'appelait
théo comment ont réagi face à cette
violence elle rejoint ce qu'on constate
dans beaucoup de villes la mienne y
compris ses drm a parfois des actes de
violence alors je connais pas les
détails mais on a on voit monter une
violence gratuite c'est dire soudaine
parce que parce que deux personnes se
sont mal parler parce que je sais pas
quoi se sont bousculés etc et c'est vrai
que la moindre anicroche parfois pas
tout le temps bien sûr heureusement peut
effectivement rapidement débordé oui
même à fontainebleau on n'échappe pas à
ça il ya la sortie des bars parfois
alors bon c'est la sortie des bars mais
des accrochages un peu violent ou équipe
qu'on ne voyait pas avant
ou vraiment la violence pure et
radicales pour en fit le pas et c'est
dommageable et une dernière question un
peu plus politique parce que vous n'en
parlez des candidats tout à l'heure vous
pour la présidentielle vous êtes plus
qu'au plus tôt vers et pécresse ont
plutôt emmanuel macron ont plutôt ni
l'un ni l'autre
écoutez je crois que d'abord fois
qu'emeric er et pécresse fois soit
candidate c'est que je les soutenais aux
élections régionales et c'est une femme
mirka cas de grande qualité la preuve
les franciliens monde ils ont plébiscité
ça c'est la première chose deuxièmement
je pense que le pays a besoin d'unité
il ya aujourd'hui un président de la
république qui fait d'aider des vraies
réformes qui sont pas éloignées de
celles que j'ai défendu lorsque j'étais
avec alain juppé de celle que je
continue à vouloir voir porter pour
notre pays
on verra comment les choses se font je
pense que même à trancher encore non
parce que la droite il se peut qu'un
jour peut-être valérie pécresse a écrit
manuel macro furmark avec dedans le dans
le dans le dans le temps le débat des
régionales elle n'a pas venir c'est
garder d'être caricaturales à l'égard du
gouvernement et du président république
comme d'autres l'ont été et cette
caricature la qui renvoie la droite
effectivement à une position qui
aujourd'hui de plus en plus marginal
fait que peut-être elle choisir un autre
chemin je n'en sais rien en disant ça je
suis pas devin je sais simplement que un
moment effectivement je pense que les
femmes et hommes de bonne volonté qui
porte la même vision
et doivent pouvoir pouvoir se rejoindre
moi c'est ce que je souhaite et on est
de plus en plus de nombreux maires vous
savez quand on est maire ont comme on a
l'habitude dit on a les pieds dans la
glaise et on est très pragmatique et
c'est vrai qu'on ait de nombreux maires
à penser qu'il ya un moment les hommes
et les femmes de bonne volonté dans une
situation économique et sociale
historique pour notre pays de
difficultés historiques et bien ferait
mieux de s'entendre plutôt effectivement
que de se combattre
merci merci
[Musique]